*Jingle Golden Moustache*
(♪)C'est très marrant!(♪)
#En 1777, Joseph II d'Autriche rend visite à son beau-frère,
à son "beauf" comme disent les jeunes,
Louis XVI, Roi de France,
parce que lui et Marie-Antoinette ont pas encore eu  d'enfant.
Alors il s'demande, que peut-être il s'passe des...
Enfin on sait pas trop, on comprend pas.
On a...il se pose vraiment beaucoup de questions.
Et c'est ce que nous allons vous raconter dans cet épisode.#
- J'espère qu'il va pas me demander de discuter c'est tout.
- Bon, Louis, faut qu'on discute!
- Oooh.
Tu veux pas qu'on aille à la chasse un peu? [aboiements]
Hein? On chasse un peu, on discute un peu?
- Non, non non non, là c'est important.
[aboiements cessent]
Faut qu'on discute, tu peux pas t'esquiver tout le temps en disant
"On va à la chasse, on va à la chasse"
- D'accord.
- C'est une question délicate, hein.
Ma sœur et toi, vous êtes mariés depuis un bon moment déjà.
- D'accord.
- Et pourtant, pas d'héritier.
- Oui.
- Pourquoi?
- D'accord.
- T'as pas compris ?
- Non.
- Bon, j'vais poser des questions simples.
Ma sœur,
la Reine...
- Autrichienne ! Facile. On va à la chasse ! [aboiements ]
- Non, c'est pas... Enfin si, Autrichienne oui.
Mais c'est pas ça !
[aboiements cessent]
En gros, vous êtes un petit couple, toi et ma sœur?
- Hmm.
- Et qu'est ce qu'ils font les petits couples? Ils...?
- Ils...
- Ils mangent ensemble.
- Hmm.
- Euh... Ils partagent des passions...
Ils discutent...
- Ils vont à la chasse... [aboiements]
- Ouais aussi et aussi...ils, ils partagent le même lit.
- Hmm.  [aboiements cessent]
- Et c'est à ce niveau là, que y'a un problème,
parce que la Reine, ma soeur,
elle est venue me voir, pour me dire :
" Joseph...
Nada !".
- Hmm.
- Joseph c'est moi.
- Mais c'était pour être sûr.                                                          - Ça, c'est bon.
- Elle m'a dit: " Avec Louis,
naaada !".
- Pourquoi elle t'a parlé espagnol?
Elle est autrichienne.
- Non mais change pas de sujet !
- On était dans un sujet ?
- OUI !
- Bon, Louis, il faut que tu te concentres !
- Hmm.
- D'accord ?
- T'es prêt ?
- Hmm.
- Comtesse de Bad Lejou !
- Ha ha ha. Oh mon vagin.
- Voilà, qu'est-ce que ça t'inspire ça ?
- Aah !
Mon pâtissier !
- Ha ha ha. Ah, des croissants.
- Non, c'était pas ça, le...
- Si le rire.
- Bon, d'accord. Euh, j'vais utiliser des références à toi. Hmm ?
Qu'est-ce que t'aimes bien dans la vie ?
- La chass--
- À part la chasse !
- Les serrures !
- Quoi? Non ooh mais ...ok d'accord.
Alors la Reine,
elle a une serrure spéciale !
- La Croquilex ! Elle a trouvé la Croquilex !
J'vais aller la voir, j'lui donne la Bretagne
contre la Croquilex. C'est fait.
- Non c'est pas ça!
T'as rien compris!
- Bah alors dis le truc que tu veux dire depuis le début !
- Pourquoi vous couchez pas ensemble ?!
- Ah ça.
Beh, ça, c'est parce que j'ai un problème ...
euh ... physiologique.
- Alors vas-y montre.
- Bah non c'est gay.
- Mais c'est ... montre, allez, quoi.
- Bah non.
-  Ohh.
- Non.
- Entre nous.
- Mais, on est d'la même famille.
- Non.
- Mais, je...c'est b--
- Non
- Allez !
- Non !
- Allez.
- Non.
- C'est pour guérir.
- Allez.
- Non.
- Allez !
- Allez.
- Ok.
- Mais c'est rien, ça !
Ça tu t'fais circoncire, c'est bon, hein.
- Sérieux ?
- Oui.
- Ah ok.
#Et c'est ainsi, que la descendance des Bourbons fut assurée.
En tout cas d'après des chaussettes.#
- (Marie-Antoinette): Mon vagin...
*Générique de fin*